bei einem Thema werden die
ampelgespräche wohl sehr entspannt
laufen man könnte sagen geradezu
gechillt und zwar bei der
cannabis-freigabe ja
und zwar alle drei Parteien sind ja
grundsätzlich dafür und was mir auffällt
selbst in hoch seriösen TV-Sendungen
melden sich begeisterte Kiffer zu Wort
ein Joint zu Entspannung einfach mal
runterkommen ja
deswegen haben sie Hofer bei der
Tagesschau rausgeschmissen
es ging nicht mehr die FDP vor allem
träumt von Gras made in Germany als
regelrechtem Exportschlager an die
20.000 Jobs könnten so angeblich
entstehen mit Cannabis vorsichtige
Schätzungen rechnen mit bis zu 2,7
Milliarden Steuereinnahmen verstehen sie
dank legal im Gras kämen sie dann
endlich die blühende Landschaften die
Kohl uns damals versprochen hat aber
gehört zu weit natürlich gibt es auch
mahnende Stimmen wie die der groko
Drogenbeauftragten Daniela Ludwig Namen
müssen sich eigentlich nicht mehr merken
immerhin hat die Frau den Kiffern im
Internet ein Zitat für die Ewigkeit
geschenkt nur weil Alkohol
möglich ist unbestritten es Cannabis
kein Brokkoli
okay
ja
ich merke es mir immer so Eselsbrücke
das eine stinkt ekelhaft und kommt mir
regelmäßig wieder hoch das andere kann
man rauchen es ist eigentlich relativ
simpel nur wenn wir alle fleißig Tüten
bauen kommt die Ampel auf ihre 50
Milliarden
kiffen für Rente und fürs Klima ja alles
andere
alles andere wäre geradezu unpatriotisch
meine Damen und Herren und mal ganz
ehrlich man kann das jetzt blöd finden
oder gefährlich die kommende
Legalisierung aber ich sag mal das Zeug
ist ja längst Mainstream ich verbreitet
sind Drogen sehr sehr sehr breiter sehr
weit verbreitet
nee war schon richtig ja
sie merken die indizienachtung
verdichten sich meine Damen und Herren
zur Wahrheit gehört bei unter
30-Jährigen also besonders bei Menschen
in der Pubertät kann Cannabis die
Entwicklung des Gehirns stören und bei
Menschen mit Veranlagung für psychische
Erkrankungen erhöht kiffen das Risiko
enorm ist das denn überhaupt bewiesen
ja doch es bewiesen da
also damit wir uns nicht missverstehen
man darf Cannabis nicht verharmlosen
auch wenn unser aller lieblingsgift also
der Alko laut Studien in jeder Hinsicht
schädlicher ist ich glaube am Ende
werden wir es wahrscheinlich so machen
wie die Kanadier also kontrollierte
Abgabe an Erwachsene und irgendwann
kommt es dann zwangsläufig in der Mitte
der Gesellschaft an
und gar nicht ihre Hanfpflanze die
wächst ja auf meinen Grundstück rüber
ach ja und was ist mit ihrem Schlafmohn
heroin ist illegal Gisela ruf mal die
Bullen
was
ja ja demnächst verkaufen sie bei
Kaffeefahrten garantiert nicht nur
Heizdecken das schwöre ich Ihnen aber es
gibt zumindest ein paar richtig gute
Argumente pro Cannabis Legalisierung zum
Beispiel die Entlastung von Polizei und
Justiz Beispiel allein 2019 gab es bei
uns über
225.000 Verfahren wegen Cannabis
83% davon ging aber gegen einfache
Konsumenten zwei Drittel wurden wieder
eingestellt wirklich was ist das für
eine absurde Zeitverschwendung und
machen Sie denn da
habe ich jetzt so grobe schon von weitem
erkannt also Verdacht hat sich bestätigt
ne so jetzt wird immer noch nicht
geraucht es wird jetzt nicht geraucht
während dieser Maßnahme
leg das weg
ja wobei ich sagen muss während der
Verhaftung kiffen ist wirklich unhöflich
das muss ja man kann Moment warten ja
danach kein Witz ist noch eine halbe
Hundertschaft angerückt um die beiden
frechen Teenies zu überwältigen was ich
damit sagen will es ist einfach
unverhältnismäßig aber gut wird ja alles
anders demnächst ist ja der Staat dann
selber der Dealer und muss höllisch
aufpassen
muss wirklich aufpassen dass uns die
Sache dann nicht entgleitet so wie in
den Niederlanden da hat ja der Staat
jahrelang überhaupt nicht gefragt wie
die Drogen in die Coffeeshops kommen und
natürlich nutzen so Drogenkartelle ihre
Lieferketten dann nicht nur für Cannabis
ist nicht so überraschend man muss es
vielleicht noch mal betonen wenn
deutsche Apotheken bald ins Geschäft
einsteigen sollten gilt das natürlich
nur für bestimmte Produkte
müde vom vielen kiffen
probier mal das hier Koka
ich bin seit 3 Tagen wach ich auch zieh
dir doch sauber an Kokain von ratiopharm
wobei Kokain hat eine wissenschaftliche
nachgewiesene Wirkung Bachblüten nicht
ich sag's nur damit wenn ich das gleiche
erleben wie die Holländer muss der Staat
das grasgeschäft komplett kontrollieren
also vom Anbau bis zum Vertrieb und
tatsächlich ist das mit den Apotheken ja
ein ernst gemeinter Vorschlag der FDP
die alte apothekerpartei ich liebe sein
Klischee ist einfach mal Stimmen falls
das so kommt wird sich natürlich die
Apotheke wie wir sie kennen drastisch
verändern wir schalten mal live zu
Matthias Matschke er Schuld jetzt fürs
Gesundheitsministerium Apotheker zu
Dealern um Herr Matschke
[Musik]
wird Dealer jetzt ein Lehrberuf
was
Herr merke ich verstehe sie total
schlecht wir haben die Musik soll laut
ja dann machen sie die noch leiser
[Musik]
super Idee
und Mama aus
der Apotheke und ich probieren uns
gerade durch die Sorten
man muss ja wissen was man verkauft
purple
White Widow Super Skunk
wie war die Frage die Frage war wird
Dealer ein Lehrberuf ja klar drei Wochen
Crashkurs und dann gibt es von der
Industrie und Handelskammer den
Meisterbrief Rauschgifthändler
das habe ich plötzlich Hunger ich habe
Tiere schon mal du auch ey komm lass mal
Pizza bestellen ich habe voll Bock auf
Pizza sorry dass ich kurz störe wie
genau Schulen sie denn da jetzt
naja du musst ja die Apotheke komplett
umgestalten früher lag hier für die
Kleinen immer die Medi und sini jetzt
liegt hier nur noch die Medi und dröhni
und Training
ja und die eigentliche Schulung kann ich
ja gar nicht machen dafür holen wir
echte Dealer aus dem Bahnhofsviertel
das ist der Ronny auf Bewährung draußen
sagen ganz lieber
findest du mich hör auf mich zu filmen
du opfer
wisst ihr was heute mir simulieren jetzt
mal ein Verkaufsgespräch ich bin jetzt
wohl der Kunde
hallo
ich interessiere mich für dieses
Haschisch
habe ich viel Gutes drüber gehört sehr
sehr gerne wie viele Gramm dürfen es
denn sein hör auf ihn voll zu Schleim
der Arsch sollte zuerst geben
ist ja wenig kriegt er nicht noch
Wechselgeld nein verpiss Dich ja aber
das war doch jetzt ein Spiel ich hätte
gerne meine zwei Fuffies wieder
weg in die Apotheke die lernen schnell
gegenüber macht eine DocMorris Apotheke
auf ey Alter das können wir uns nicht
gefallen lassen das hier ist unsere
Schweine machen wir fertig ey Leute
aber bitte nicht mit Gewalt das können
wir uns als Staat nicht leisten Matthias
Matschke vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Audi Leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines Abo bitten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
na los
na los du scheiß Pferd hey